[Music]
till now we've only been looking at the
properties of an image formed by concave
mirror however there is one more type of
a curved mirror do we know what it's
called yes a convex mirror so what is
the convex mirror a mirror whose
reflecting surface is curved outward is
called a convex mirror the question now
is how does an image formed by a convex
mirror look like without further ado
let's find that out we will draw a table
on the right just like we did for a
concave mirror here is a convex mirror
suppose an object is kept at a finite
distance away from it look carefully at
its image formed can you already tell me
the properties of the image by just
looking at it first of all we conclude
that the image is smaller in size
compared to the object this is very
clear the image is diminished the light
rays seem to come from the point behind
the mirror but obviously we know that no
image is formed there so this is a
virtual image also it's an upright image
remember that every virtual image is an
upright image what if I move the object
towards the mirror if I move the object
towards the mirror the size of the image
keeps on increasing but the size of the
image with respect to the object is
always smaller what will happen if I
move the object away from the mirror as
I move the object away from the mirror
the relative size of the image keeps on
reducing also at any finite distance
away from the mirror image formed is
always a virtual image you know what's
coming next don't you yes what if the
object is infinitely far away well in
the case of a concave mirror when the
object was infinitely far away the image
was formed at a single point it was real
point sized and a highly diminished
image point sized means that the whole
image of the object is formed at a thing
point here - the same thing happens
image formed is indeed point sized but
here the image is a virtual image so
when the object is kept at infinity the
image formed is virtual point sized and
highly diminished notice that even
though the object is kept at infinity
the image is not at infinity it is at a
finite distance behind the mirror even
though the object is infinitely far away
in fact this is the maximum distance at
which image can be formed image in a
convex mirror cannot be formed behind
this point we will now represent the
image formed by a convex mirror using
Ray diagrams let's try to draw a ray
diagram for this case first this is when
the object is at infinity our object
will be the usual arrow and suppose it's
at infinity now if you remember I told
you that the rays of light coming from
the object at infinity are considered to
be parallel to each other and we know
that two rays are sufficient to draw a
ray diagram so we will take any two
parallel rays striking the mirror these
rays will be reflected in such a way
that laws of reflection are obeyed we
notice that the rays are diverging after
reflection and when we extend these rays
backwards they meet at a single point
which is the principal focus in this
case what does this imply when we are
looking at the image of an infinitely
far away object it appears to be formed
at this single point behind the mirror
if the parallel rays are traveling in
this direction the image is still formed
at a single point which is different
than the principal focus we call this
point focus as it does not lie on the
principal axis what now now let's keep
the object at a finite distance from the
mirror and try to represent the image
formed for this case using a ray diagram
so how did we proceed we only need to
take any two points on the object which
is represented by this arrow find out
the image of these two objects points
first by drawing at least two rays
emerging from each
point after reflection all these rays
will follow the laws of reflection when
we extend these rays backwards we get
our image locations I repeat again that
this is not a real location in space
it's only a location where the image
appears to be formed I want to pause
here for a moment
to tell you the reason exactly why I
chose these two rays only one parallel
to the principal axis and the other
directed towards the focal point yes
these are not random two rays
I chose them on purpose well if you
remember when we were talking about the
Ray diagrams for images formed by
concave mirrors we thought that the rays
which are parallel to the mirror will
always pass through the focal point
after reflection and the rays which pass
through the focal point will always
travel parallel to the principal axis
after reflection there we had only used
these two rays to draw all of our ray
diagrams but in convex mirrors we know
that the race cannot pass through the
focal point as it lies behind the mirror
but if I direct the incident ray towards
the focal point then after reflection it
travels parallel to the principal axis
yes
any ray which is directed towards the
focal point it will travel parallel to
the principal axis after reflection also
if the incident ray is traveling
parallel to the principal axis then
after reflection it will look as if it
originated from the focal point for
instance here all these reflected Ray's
seem to be coming from this focal point
with this bit of knowledge let's jump
back to where we were initially now I
think you understood the reason behind
my choice of these two rays okay
so let's quickly join these image points
to get the complete image of the object
if we measure the length of the object
and the image we will find that the
object size is greater than its image so
we say that the image is diminished also
one more important thing that I must say
is that the images distance from the
mirror is not the same as the objects
distance from the mirror
if you remember when we were discussing
plane mirror images the virtual image
distance and object distance from the
mirror were the same irrespective of
where the object was placed here even
though it's a virtual image it does not
follow that property so these two other
ray diagrams representing the image and
its properties when the object is
infinitely away from the mirror we get a
point size image at the focal point and
as we keep moving the object towards the
mirror the size of the image keeps
increasing and it appears to be coming
closer to the back side of the mirror in
the next video we will see some uses of
concave and convex mirrors in real life
[Music]